des parcelles ravagé des récoltes
catastrophiques
ici aux alentours de vernouillet les
inondations n'ont pas fait de cadeau aux
maraîchers le président du conseil
départemental des yvelines pierre bédier
s'est rendu sur place ce mercredi pour
soutenir ces agriculteurs en détresse
c'est important d'autant plus importante
d aider que c'est de leur part très
courageux parce que leurs discussions
c'est pas indemnisés ni leurs
discussions c'est aidez nous à
travailler société où le travail n'est
plus une valeur centrale avoir des gens
qui disent
aidez nous à travailler c'est un peu
normal qu'on se mobilise pour eux cet
agriculteur a vu 32 c 32 hectares être
inondé la semaine dernière il estime
aujourd'hui son préjudice à 500000 euros
excédés par le manque de réactivité de
l'état peu de solutions s'offrent à lui
moi j'ai évoqué éventuellement le dépôt
de bilan
première solution c'est un outil de
gestion pour éventuellement redémarrer
soit une cessation d'activité ou soit
j'aurais relancé avec le concours je
dirais de l'état
si l'état nous amène des mesurettes
comme je ré comme d'habitude parce qu'on
les connaît les recettes il ressortait
même c'est pas une solution
sauver les emplois et les récoltes de
ces maraîchers
c'est l'objectif que s'est fixé le
département une subvention
exceptionnelle à la chambre
d'agriculture d'île de france sera
soumise au vote le 17 juin prochain